japanese billionaire is the first
passenger to book a trip to the moon on
a SpaceX rocket CEO Elon Musk
join us aku Misawa at the company's
California headquarters yesterday my
zawa paid an undisclosed amount to ride
on SpaceX's new big Falcon rocket musk
says the project will cost five billion
dollars and could be ready as early as
2023
Mireya Villarreal spoke to the Japanese
billionaire after the announcement I
chose to go to the moon in front of a
packed house SpaceX founder Elon Musk
introduced his newest partner in space
exploration billionaire Utah kumazawa I
thought about how I can give back to the
world and how this can contribute to
world peace
this is my lifelong dream the founder of
Japan's largest retail website misawa
purchased every seat on the trip and
plans to bring up to eight artists along
for the ride these artists will be asked
to create something after they return to
Earth and these masterpieces we are
inspired at Rema within all of us the
bfr rocket will be nearly 400 feet long
and equipped with a reusable booster
rocket that will produce 200 tons of
thrust the plan is to send passengers
around the moon and back a more than
four hundred and seventy-five thousand
mile journey in about five days this is
a dangerous mission but it's definitely
dangerous
I'm not afraid though that's all you're
not afraid at all no wow
I thought the space X team but SpaceX
has had problems meeting deadlines its
last rocket the Falcon Heavy had its
first successful launch in nearly five
years later than expected what makes you
so sure that you can actually meet that
2023 deadline it's not a harm percent
certain that we succeed in getting this
to flight but we're gonna do everything
humanly possible to bring it to flight
as fast as we can
and as safely as we can it's a risky
investment 42 year old Misawa is willing
to make for a shot at a lunar legacy for
CBS this morning Media VL in Hawthorne
California listen I admire people that
say it's gonna be a dangerous mission
but I'm not afraid I'm going mm-hmm I'm
the one going I'm doing the moonwalk the
other way the spirit of the discovery
yeah I know I don't think so no they run
a few tests first you know they're like
a good adventure but I'm not I know
you're not going to this plate of moon
pies that's a starter place
yes I'll share that with you John
Dickerson